jeff bezos copycat bill gates
founder of the pandemic mark zuckerberg
possibly a lizard
but we aren't sure walden family
parasites
donald trump very orange elon musk
however
the great almighty but why
generally there's two camps of people
one camp believes that
everyone who exceeds a certain amount of
wealth is inherently evil to some extent
as they argue that it is impossible
for an individual to accumulate such
massive wealth
without at least a few questionable
decisions down the line
conversely the other camp does agree
that billionaires generally have
negative aspects about them however they
believe that the pros brought on by
these billionaires
as well as their companies far outweigh
their cons
personally i'm part of the second camp
as i strongly believe that the value
offered by google and facebook and apple
are
far greater than the privacy concerns
and security threats that they may pose
but then again these three companies are
basically my life
so this may be radically different for
you
however in this video i'm not concerned
about the pro-billionaire versus
anti-billionaire argument as there's an
even more
interesting third camp the individuals
in this camp
believe orange man is bad and the
lizards are spying on us
but elon musk though gets the green flag
this notion has been especially evident
in the comments of some of my most
recent videos
for instance when i pointed out that
elon musk receives billions of dollars
per year
but likely pays little taxes we received
two types of comments
first we received comments suggesting
that elon musk
only receives stock compensation if he
meets growth targets
and this is absolutely true but
isn't this the same case with nearly
every other billionaire ceo
as well whether it's under pichai or tim
cook
they have to deliver on quarter-round
quarter growth and year-on-year growth
if they want to cash in on the big
incentives aside from this
we had several comments pointing out
that elon musk not paying taxes
is not his fault as it's not him who's
writing the tax laws
but then why is it wrong if amazon pays
no taxes
or if donald trump pays no taxes i'm
sure
that they have hundreds if not thousands
of financial accountants
ensuring that though their tax returns
might be sketchy
they are not illegal when these
individuals don't pay their taxes
the situation is often painted as these
greedy pigs not owning up to their
economic responsibility
as opposed to it's not their fault it's
the government
so what's the psychology behind only
liking elon musk in terms of
billionaires
well the first point that came to mind
was the impact
of their work elon musk is no doubt one
of the most innovative thinkers
on planet earth and is often argued to
be the most important person alive by
many experts
but while this is definitely true it is
not the impact of his work per se
that causes individuals to view elon
musk favorably
if this was the case then bill gates
would have a much more positive social
image
bill gates has donated 50 billion
dollars to charity since 1994
and he has been a massive help in
vaccinating africa
with his help several african countries
were
actually able to surpass vaccination
raids of north america
over five years ago of course this
is aided by anti-vaxxers within north
america
but near 100 vaccination rates are no
question
very very good with that being said
i would actually argue that this is more
important than elon musk's work
according to the world health
organization a child
dies from malaria every two minutes as a
result
i believe that it's much more important
to create and spread vaccinations for
terrible diseases
like malaria and measles to prevent tens
of thousands of children from dying on a
regular basis
in comparison to slowing down the
effects of climate change or colonizing
mars
don't get me wrong here all of these
issues are very important for long-term
sustainability
but i do think short-term threats take
priority over long-term threats
moreover if we take a look at long-term
threats
jeff bezos is also aiming to positively
impact climate change
and air pollution using his rocket
company blue origin
which was actually founded before spacex
so considering bill gates and jeff bezos
lackluster public images
despite their great contributions it's
clear that
it's not the impact of the work itself
that's the most important
moving on the second reason that comes
to mind when attempting to explain a
person's support for an individual
we have personal gain donald trump says
crazy crap
but many of his supporters will back him
to their debts
as they believe that he is the key to
them getting their jobs back
or that he is the only barrier between
them and socialist bernie
et cetera however this is really not the
case with elon musk either
as most of his work is addressing
long-term issues
again this is not to say that his work
is not useful
by any means but rather that most of the
perks of his work
won't come till decades in the future
for instance
if you have a toilet that's not working
you're likely going to go onto google
or youtube and look up some tutorials
and
if you need a special part or tool
that's not available
at nearby hardware stores you'll likely
order this at products with amazon prime
clearly the services offered by the evil
billionaires
are actually much more useful for
day-to-day use cases
as opposed to colonizing mars this means
that it is also
not immediate personal gain that has
gotten so many people rallied
around elon musk but then what is it
well i believe that the first major
reason elon musk is so churched
is the nobility of his work though elon
musk is not the only billionaire
engaged in great social causes he is the
only one who has drive the vast majority
of his world
from said causes elon musk did have zip
and paypal in his early days but the
payouts from these endeavors
account for well below one percent of
his net worth today
for individuals like jeff bezos and bill
gates
these percentages are often the other
way around
bill gates did donate 50 billion dollars
which can never be twisted into a bad
thing as
this requires a massive heart and a
simply extraordinary philanthropy
but at the same time it should be noted
that bill gates made
even more money during the same time
period similarly
though jeff bezos is thinking billions
of dollars per year
into improving space exploration and
colonization
this is just a mere percentage of his
wealth
first of all i would like to say that
neither of these guys
are obliged to give away any of their
wealth and
any wealth they do donate or invest into
future industries
is commendable the reason i bring up
these points
is because elon musk slightly beats out
these guys in this realm
for bill gates and jeff bezos giving
away billions of dollars today
doesn't affect their overall financial
state or well-being
again this does not take away from the
weight of their philanthropic work
however elon musk has risked everything
he has
several times to try to push forward ev
and space technology as a result though
other billionaires have also made large
contributions
elon musk may be perceived as having
more noble intentions
as his businesses themselves were
centered on improving society
and this is where he derived his wealth
from
on the flip side other billionaires
generally built their businesses
in other industries first and made most
of their money there
and then later they focus on giving back
moving on
the next major reason i believe people
prefer elon to other billionaires
is because he is the only one at the top
who is not known for their immense
amounts of wealth
jeff bezos has been the ceo of amazon
since the very beginning
in 1994 and amazon has made him very
rich
throughout the years in fact jeff bezos
was worth 7.8
billion dollars way back in 1999
and he was the 18th richest person in
the world
way back then he would fluctuate up and
down
over the years but he would remain
within the top 50
for the most part moreover amazon was
quite large back then as well
but the average person didn't know jeff
bezos
even in 2015 jeff bezos was the number
four
richest person in the world with 47
billion dollars
but people still didn't really care
within the next two to three years
however
he jumps from four to one and nearly
quadruples his wealth
and now everyone knows him because all
the headlines are
amazon ceo takes over bill gates as the
richest person
in the world to this day i don't think
the average person would be able to name
the ceo
of amazon however what the average
person does know
is amazon's monopoly amazon has
seemingly bad working conditions
amazon doesn't pay taxes and through all
of this
amazon ceo is the richest person in the
world
thus amazon ceo equals bad
similarly bill gates is known for
dominating the billionaires list for
decades
upon decades and mark zuckerberg is the
one who hit a big in his early
20s becoming the world's youngest
billionaire at the time
and of course we have warren buffett the
oracle of omaha
and there's donald trump who was so rich
that he could get a million dollar loan
from his dad
and call it small as you can see
everyone else at the top that are well
known
are well known because they're rich not
because they're innovative
hardworking or positive people jeff
bezos has brought this up several times
actually
pointing out that his fame is simply
because of his wealth
he has pointed out that he'd rather be
seen as inventor jeff bezos
or father jeff bezos but rather
he's seen as the richest person in the
world jeff bezos
conversely the average person doesn't
know elon musk
for his wealth the first thing that
comes to mind when it comes to elon musk
is not his massive fortune but rather
rockets and
clean energy and electric vehicles and i
believe that these are the two main
reasons that elon musk
is viewed so favorably his wealth gains
are seen
as originating from noble projects and
his clout
is not derived from his wealth itself
but rather
his contributions unlike his fellow
billionaires
why do you guys think elon musk is so
beloved
unlike his colleagues comment that down
below also
consider joining our community discord
to suggest future video ideas
and drop a like if you guys love elon
musk
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you